bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france cette prime
exceptionnelle accordée aux
établissements et services
médico-sociaux a fait l'objet d'un
décret à part avec donc un des montants
là qui vont de 500 à 1500 euros
escalettes à la hauteur de vos attentes
mais déjà dans un premier temps en ce qu
on dit que c'est une revalorisation
salariale
les primes ou sait on n'en veut pas ça
fait ya eu des mois de mobilisation dans
le socle commun de toutes les
organisations qui ont manifesté il y
avait la revalorisation salariale
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un
gouvernement a voulu faire un geste
envers les soignants c'était cette
revalorisation qu'il fallait discuter et
aujourd'hui on nous attribue une prime
qui est très disparate il ya des
secteurs qui ne rompt pas et le privé on
n'en parle pas on sait pas il ya des
départements qui l'auront pas qu'ils ont
été aussi touché 1 car il faut savoir
que ben on est tous susceptibles d'avoir
pris en charge des patients qu'aux vide
donc ça c'est un premier point aidés par
des porteurs sains tous les blocs
opératoires de france se sont mis en
ordre de marche pour prendre en charge
ces patients
il ya eu une grosse organisation en
amont donc ce qu'on demande à la limite
sur la prime c'est qu'il ya un effort
national et que tout le monde touche la
prime que ce soit pas uniquement
certains départements et d'autres non
cette prime vous dites je reprends vous
reprendre vos termes vous dites que vous
ne voulez pas voilà clairement
clairement nous c'est depuis le début
des mobilisations deux mois une
revalorisation salariale
parce qu'on sait très bien reconnaît le
gouvernement on sait très bien comment
ça va se passer
ils vont donner une prime ça va au
niveau de l'esprit collectif les gens
vont dire bon bah ils ont leurs primes
en plus on va avoir notre médaille donc
on est on est super heureux
donc si vous voulez on va s'arrêter à la
parce qu'on sait très bien commencé
avant vous ça va fonctionner après il
faut savoir que les hôpitaux étaient
grandement impacté il ya un impact
économique avec les hôpitaux qui ont
tourné au ralenti
donc la suite des événements on la
connaît pas c'est encore trop flou donc
aujourd'hui la prime n'est entièrement
clairement on n'en veut pas clairement
on veut une revalorisation salariale
pour tous les soignants et avec une
traduction aussi dans le privé parce
qu'on a nos collègues du privé qui sont
clairement oublié on sait pas si voilà
des services qui ont pris en charge et a
aussi notamment la médecine de ville les
infirmières libérales donc tous tous ces
personnels là on s'est passé dans le
flou
alors à ce sujet justement concernant
l'avenir emmanuel macron s'est rendu ce
matin pour une visite surprise de
l'hôpital parisien de la
pitié-salpêtrière il a promis d'investir
il dit avoir demandé un travail express
sur le sujet il a aussi assuré vouloir
aller plus vite notamment pour
revaloriser les rémunérations et les
carrières comment est-ce que vous
accueillez ce propos écoutez c'est lui
qui le dit la presse ça fait des mois
qu'on les sollicite au niveau du
gouvernement avec l'intersyndicale et
l'intercollectif il n'y a aucune
discussion avec eux donc si vous voulez
on n'en sait rien on est dans le flou
artistique
c'est des promesses depuis le début il a
fait beaucoup de promesses donc nous
j'ai en tant que soignant on n'y croit
plus du tout
clairement on est on est au fait on sait
très bien comment ça va se passer par la
suite
donc on reste sur nos gardes tant que
tant qu'on n'a pas vu tant qu'on n'est
pas invité aux négociations autre chose
banana en est on
on sait pas est ce que vous ne pensez
pas que cette crise sanitaire qui a
évidemment très fortement marqué les
esprits et plus changer la donne
emmanuel macron disait notamment ce
matin il reconnaissait une erreur dans
la réforme du système de santé qui a été
engagé il y a deux ans et il a insisté
pour mettre fin à la paupérisation des
personnels soignants
c'est une forme de mea culpa l'un
nettement on n'y croit plus à ce que je
vous disais les politiques c'est
toujours très compliqué là ils ont un
discours est derrière ces d'autres
choses qui se produisent donc qu'ils
nous prouvent qu'ils le prouvent
clairement qu'ils qui nous invite à
atteindre et qui est on discute des
salaires il faut on va pas le répéter on
a en fait partie des pays dossier des
acquis et les infirmiers sont les moins
bien payés
je veux dire c'est pas nous qui
l'inventa c'est une organisation
internationale d'études qui le dit donc
qu'il le prouve maintenant et rapidement
il n'y a pas d'autre mot viendrait ici
pour votre réaction rachida digoit
président du collectif inter bloc
infirmier au centre hospitalier de
chalon sur saône